un día después de que el parlamento
israelí ratificarse por una escasísima
mayoría el nuevo gobierno de coalición
liderado por naftalí bennett quien es
por cierto el primer primer ministro de
israel religioso este se reunió con
quien le tenía que dar el traspaso de
poderes el ya ex primer ministro
benjamin netanyahu
netanyahu le otorgó a vélez apenas media
hora de su tiempo para hacer dicho
traspaso y suele ser una ceremonia con
un cierto ceremonial fotos buenas
palabras nada de eso hubo en esta
ocasión ni siquiera fotos a la salida
del traspaso de poderes netania o si
dijo a la prensa que pretendía volver
con toda la fuerza para arrebatar el
poder a este gobierno que dice está
basado en la mentira en el fraude y en
las ansias de poder también recomendó a
sus partidarios que se unieran porque
sólo la cohesión podrá lograr desbancar
al nuevo gobierno
por su parte el resto del extenso nuevo
gobierno de coalición son 28 ministros
de los cuales 9 son mujeres lo cual es
un récord en israel también se pusieron
a trabajar inmediatamente porque el
traspaso de poderes se produjo en el
mismo día de hoy